economía en directo américa de france 24
ya está conmigo en el estudio daniela
blandón danny bienvenida feliz jueves
feliz día de acción de gracias una
festividad que eeuu pero yo la verdad la
celebraba con mi familia siempre en una
cena y hablamos ahora esto porque los
alimentos están más caros que nunca dio
la impresión de eeuu claro raúl yo
también solía celebrar este día de
acción de gracias y sí claro me parece
fantástico pues miren dicen en que los
pavos no pueden volar alto raúl o lo que
sí están volando alto son los precios sí
porque mire los precios de muchos
alimentos en eeuu en la pandemia se han
disparado sobre todo en el último año la
mesa de acción de gracias' no se ha
librado de este fenómeno desde luego
debido a la escasez de mano de obra y
también a la fuerte demanda de los
consumidores pues el american farm
bureau realiza una encuesta anual en la
que promedió a los costos del banquete
para 10 personas y este año por primera
vez desde 2015 subió dice el estudio que
en 2021 tendrá un costo de un poco más
de 53 dólares para día o un 14 más que
el año pasado daniela que incluye esta
escena además se preguntó cuánto han
subido los precios yo gracias a dios no
como pago entonces
claro por ciento pues mire por lo menos
le el menú que tiene éste american farm
bureau es de un pago de 16 libras que en
apenas un año subió un 24 por ciento de
precio también panecillos que valen 3
dólares por docena un 15% más que el año
pasado y arándanos frescos cuya bolsa de
11 de 12 onzas puede rondar los 3
dólares o un 11% más caros también
incluye batatas verduras y hasta un
pastel según el análisis que hace esta
firma otra encuesta del departamento de
agricultura de eeuu muestra que la
canasta de alimentos básicos para día de
acción de gracias subió por lo menos un
5,5 por ciento este año y lo que también
se ha disparado este año es la gasolina
pero eso no fue impedimento para que
unos 50 millones de viajeros por tierra
solamente por tierra hayan empacado
maletas este año para festejar el stand
es que mi capitán kevin ahorita hablamos
de la inflación pero esta vez en el
vecino del sur de eeuu hablas de méxico
miren la primera quincena de noviembre
la inflación interanual en este país
llegó al 70 5% según el departamento de
estadísticas es un su aumento más alto
en 20 años desde abril de 2001 raúl y
entre lo que más están subiendo son los
precios de los productos agropecuarios
con un 12 37 por ciento mientras que las
tarifas energéticas se han elevado en
más del 11 por ciento
estos datos se agravan una economía ya
afectada por la depreciación del peso y
por los inesperados cambios en el banco
de méxico cuyo presidente lo
comentábamos ayer irá hasta el 31 de
diciembre ahora después de conocerse que
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador había desistido de su primer
candidato a la gobernación del banco
central la propuesta ahora incluye a la
subsecretaria de egresos de la
secretaría de hacienda quienes son maría
victoria rodríguez danny que le pasó al
toro durado the walt suite parece que no
le gustó mucho ahora sino porque raúl
mira apenas duró siete días en pie
sao paulo era una réplica de la estatua
del famoso toro dorado de wallstreet de
manhattan hecha de metal y fibra de
vidrio había sido instalada frente a la
bolsa de sao paulo en el centro de la
ciudad como un hito bastante llamativo
pero sobre ello se había apagado por
protestas al día siguiente un grupo de
estudiantes colocó calcomanías que
decían hambre en el cuerpo del toro como
se puede ver en las imágenes y se
hicieron virales en redes sociales y es
que hay quienes consideran que de
ninguna manera reflejaba la actual
encrucijada económica del país con una
pobreza galopante y también una
inflación y un desempleo de dos dígitos
pues ellos raúl no tuvieron que esperar
mucho para que se derrumbara por orden
de la propia bolsa de valores y de la
alcaldía la escultura fue retirada y
cuánto dinero se perdió ahí pues ya
íbamos a saber daniela indicadores
económicos los mercados bursátiles del
mundo suben este jueves empezando por
las bolsas asiáticas con excepción de
seúl que subió tasas de interés también
lo hacen las bolsas europeas todo
después de que funcionarios de la
reserva federal de ésta dos unidos
indicarán que estaban listos para
comenzar a subir las tasas de interés
antes de lo previsto si es necesario
para enfriar la inflación para finalizar
danny que nos trae como cifra el día 8
por ciento fue la caída del gasto de los
hogares de la unión europea en 2020
frente al año anterior según el
departamento de estadística está la
mayor reducción anual y se notó más en
restaurantes y hoteles que tuvo una
caída del 38 por ciento y ropa y calzado
17 por ciento fue la caída usted que es
medio europeo lo debe saber ser 100%
daniela
muchísimas gracias dani por toda la
información nos vemos más adelante con
más economía aquí en directo américa
vamos a ver ahora nuestro reportaje